30 to 60 minutes every single day on
your business hey everyone welcome to
another Evans book update video I like
to talk a lot about on the China on how
you need to spend 30 to 60 minutes at
least every single day on your business
because it's easy for life to get in the
way it's easy for us to come up with
with real reasons not just excuses but
real reason is so why we can't do
something right maybe you have another
job a full-time job that you worried
about maybe your family is sick or
something happened and life often seems
to get in the way and it's easy to mail
it is easy to say I'm too tired it's
easy to just not want to get up and go
to work and do something but that's what
defines you right like the struggle
defines you right if it was so easy to
do it if you had unlimited time of
course you would spend enough time on
your business it's that your time is
limited you don't have the time to go
all in on it and yeah you need to make
sure that you don't let that dream die
because too many people that's what they
do they let their dream die you have
this vision for what you want to do but
because light keeps getting in the way
it's never the right time and the result
you never end up taking action and so no
matter what's happening in your life at
the moment no matter what negative
things are going on no matter what's
consuming your time you need to make
sure that you're spending at least 30 to
60 minutes every single day to take that
dream that you have and move it forward
30 60 minutes you can find the time to
do it and so today is a perfect example
of a day where it's easy to mail it in
I'm sick first of all I'm starting to
get better I appreciate all the awesome
comments you guys left on last week's
video but me getting better Nina finally
made me go to a walk in clinic and get
some medication I am now taking these
giant pills you should see these pills
this is what they this is the package
like those are huge you gotta take two
of those every day anyway starting to
feel better if we show a comment but
I've got a little bit low energy lower
than usual I've got Hayden home because
it's the week before Christmas when this
is being filmed I guess it's gonna go
out on Boxing Day so merry christmas
everybody but Hayden's over his cousin
is over sleeping over here too for the
week and so we've got like fake teeth
everywhere
what's this magic trick boxes and a
whole bunch of stuff and just a lot of a
lot of energy and time having to work
with the kids make sure they're
entertained and not just not just
sitting them down in front of a computer
and letting them watch stuff all day
right actually trying to do stuff with
them top of that I get a call from my
mom to say my dad's sick and he need to
go to the clinic and so I just came back
from spending two and a half hours with
him at the clinic turns out just looks
like a case of really bad food
poisonings but they still gave him some
antibiotics and anyway at this point I
just wanna I just want to lie down relax
but I I haven't done any work on my book
yet today is my book day and I need to
get work done and there's some good
progress it needs to get done I've gotta
edit some of the final chapters we're
getting really close and so I'm gonna be
spending time tonight after Hayden and
his cousin go to bed probably 60 to 90
minutes I'm thinking of work of editing
we'll see how it goes but you know it's
just one of those days where it's easy
to mail it in it's easy to say I've got
so much happening I'm exhausted you know
I'm sick I'm looking after my my parents
im looking after my kid there's just no
time left for me and I find the time
because that's gonna happen in your life
and you need to find the time you need
to carve it out you gotta make an
importance of every single day something
is happening to move your dream and make
it closer to a reality so there's a few
questions I want to get to from you guys
and we'll see how it goes so the first
one came in I can't pronounce the name I
apologize wrote in to say it seems funny
for me that I learned English from your
videos day by day and prove my skills
and I feel like I get better with all
these stuff i watch on your YouTube
channel thanks for what you're doing be
healthy as hell and never get sick best
regards from Russia this is a really
cool story and i took this question
because uh my mom came from Europe and
moved to Canada when she was young and
didn't know any English and she'd
learned from watching TV shows that's
how she got her English to get really
really good and she now doesn't have an
accent understands all the rules of
English better than most people and you
would never know that she was an
immigrant and I thought that's really
cool that that's part of how she learned
English and it's just a full circle
moment for me really amazing that other
people are now doing that to their
learning English
from watching my content so I think
that's really cool and thank you so much
for leaving that feedback and glad it's
having an impact on your life next up
marwa thank you so much for all the
information Evan I believe that your
book will amaze us will you be able to
reach it in Egypt as I hope I don't see
why it won't be available in Egypt I
don't know i'm pretty sure can be
available in Egypt again I don't know
why wouldn't be I don't know if I'll
make up a stop and Egypt on the tour you
never know hey there's a lot of Egyptian
people who want me to go and make a tour
stop then I might just do that again I
haven't thought too much about the
marketing side of things yet I want to
finish the book deadlines coming up I
want to have it in the hands of my
publisher work through the editing and
then have a call on I want to see
january eight whatever the friday is it
says it's a friday in the new year
anyway have a call with a with a
publicity person at the publishing
company to discuss the marketing
strategies which is much it's exciting
right i'm excited things like hey this
is coming up we're going to launch it
and so and of course you know as we go
through this process i'll keep you guys
updated and let you know but yes i'd
love to get to Egypt my not pretty thank
you very much for this very useful tip
I'm looking forward to release of the
book please keep up the good work i wish
you a speedy recovery thank you again
tons of awesome comments uh just wishing
me to get better it's awesome knowing
that i'm just sitting here talking to a
video camera and it's reaching lots of
people and it's having an impact on your
life and that's why i do it you know
that's why I do it I love being able to
help help inspire people and I love
hearing your stories and just knowing
that the message is being reached and is
being acted upon makes me feel good
that's why I keep doing it for you and
then question from a new future builder
this topic of clarity is amazing thank
you on this and I look to become even
more clear and I have an interesting
question do you think there is a
movement for founder CEO senior
executives to become the face of their
big companies and brands in terms of
marketing and content creation for
example oh I think it got cut off I
think you had Grant Cardone in there and
Gary Vaynerchuk is there a trend towards
these CEOs being the brand I think I
think it's always been there I think
it's a personality thing I think some
founders some CEOs are much more visible
and like
being in the spotlight you think you go
all the back to PT Barnum who was the
master showman and even if you move
through the generations you look at you
look at us Steve Jobs right who was the
face of Apple and was so good at
delivering amazing presentations it
wasn't just attack but people looked up
to him and then there's a bunch of
people who if you look at the you look
at the Forbes list of the wealthiest
people in the world probably more than
half of them you'd never recognize them
you have no idea who they are you don't
have to be a Type A personality you
don't have to be in the media you don't
have to be the expert the face to become
successful I think it's much more about
if that's your personality if that's
your strength then you want to go all in
on it because why not bet on the
strengths that you have I think it's
just now people are moving away from
maybe traditional media or blogs you
know Mark Cuban had his blog for the
longest time I don't know if he still
does and people moving towards YouTube
now and Twitter and other social media
platform so I think it really just
depends on what you're good at what you
want to learn where your passion is
where your interests are if you're
someone like Grant Cardone or Gary
Vaynerchuk or or even you know bigger
names and that's a natural skill set of
yours then it makes absolute sense to do
that I know Gary Vee as an example hates
the right and he's on his third book i
want to say now and it's all kind of
ghost written with his approval from
interviews that he's done and stuff but
he doesn't actually write any of it he
likes to be in front of the camera right
and he's really good at it and it's one
of the only channels that i watch pretty
much every new video that comes out on
and so I see more and more entrepreneurs
doing that if that's in their skill set
but I wouldn't want you guys to go ahead
and do it because you see me putting up
videos you see Gary Vee putting up
videos and say well it works for him
actually go do it you know if it's not
in your skill set if you don't want to
learn it if it feels like a George or
that's a job and chore combine jor jor
jor if it feels like a job or a chore
then you shouldn't do it right then then
you're not going to have a lot of
success with it you should find what
works for you so I think it's always
been a part always will be just the
platforms people use will change as
technology and society changes so that's
it thank you
guys are joining I hope you're having an
amazing holiday season I'm looking
forward to getting better i'm looking
forward to my father getting better i'm
looking forward to getting a little bit
of work done on the book 30 to 60
minutes every single day on your
business Christmas New Year's Eve New
Year's Day no excuses you can find the
time thank you guys for watching if you
have a question for me for the next
video either but the topic of getting
work done about the book that I'm
writing or about the book writing
process that you curious about leave it
in the comments below and i will make a
video response for you next week thank
you so much for watching continue to
believe and i'll see you soon